uh one of my favorite stories related to
white supremacy
is about this guy named craig cobb kreb
craig cobb i interviewed him on the
program he was one of these guys who
wants a whites only community i think in
one of the dakotas
and i interviewed him and it was a total
gong show of an interview and he accused
me of
uh [ __ ] wordsmithing that was sort of a
key phrase that came out of the
interview with craig cobb
he later went on some tv talk show and
they did one of those dna tests like i i
did one of these
with a ancestry.com and they ran
a dna test for craig cobb and it turned
out that he was like 14 or 15
black i think the number was and of
course he said oh it's a completely
bogus
dna test so with him his ideas didn't
change but it turned out that his
identity was
at a bit of a conflict with his ideology
i have a new story that's along these
same lines and it's just as interesting
there's a white supremacist who has been
involved in
i think they call it the movement for
decades
who has come out as a gay jew i'm
talking about kevin wilshaw who
announced that he's leaving white
supremacy
and not only that he announced that he
is a gay man and of course
lgbt individuals are typically hated
by these extremist groups and that's not
altogether
shocking actually wilshaw said that
there's a number of
lgbt individuals within the white
supremacy movement
and yes he does see it as a
contradiction there's actually a
particularly well-known case it's
totally unrelated to wilshaw there was a
guy named
nikki crane a british neo-nazi activist
who came out as gay before dying
actually of aids-related illness in
1993. so kevin wilshaw
long-time white supremacist he says he's
actually gay but not only that
he also has announced that he has jewish
heritage
which is another group that obviously is
hated by these extremist groups
it turns out that kevin wilshaw's mother
was part jewish her last name benjamin
and he has been speaking out against
jews about just how
terrible and bad jews are for decades
and now he says that you know
he doesn't see jews as this sort of
nameless amorphous group he really has
no choice
but to see jews as people uh
and he is removing himself from the
movement so first things first
anyone that separates from these
movements from these groups
should be applauded that's a really good
thing but once again and i've been
talking about this now for some time
the fact that people only realize the
error of their bigoted
and totally discriminatory ways when it
personally hits them
is a real concern to me because it
should not be that difficult for members
of society
to realize even if i'm not personally
affected by this
it's bad it's bad because i have some
sense of
empathy for other people and we talked
about this after the las vegas shooting
when some country music
guitarist i believe it was came out and
said you know i've been a long time
advocate of more guns in more places and
the second amendment and blah blah blah
but it took this event to make me
realize that i've been on the wrong side
of that
anytime someone changes their opinion
for the better for the more logical for
the more empathetic that's a good thing
but what's happening in society that it
takes a personal incident
to realize that your views are
destructive discriminatory and really
damaging to people all over the world
is it that difficult to just treat
people the way you'd like to be treated
apparently it is